welcome to this video playing Prince
panic Villa Hendricks the national
master really Hendricks from the
Netherlands and we have an Italian game
once again I have this against him all
the time I'm always playing Bishop c4
lines it is a little bit different
though I i won't play a 96 I don't need
to in this particular move order yeah
the Italian game it's nothing that
scares black very much but it is
definitely quite a solid choice for what
it's a decent alternative to the
reuleaux pass if you want somewhat less
force game but want to avoid them the
big theoretical discussions that might
happen in their way yeah so interesting
area I wanted to put a little bit of oil
into the higher with getting this pawn
to f4 and it's really a little bit of a
big porn mg5 is a move that I don't know
if I want to play that but if he goes
Queen d2 I mean I can maybe protect yeah
maybe I can do that like Queen f6 is got
night h 294
interesting yeah still he should play
Queen d2 play 22 Queen f6 I know he's
going with this this was my my secondary
idea so that I have 96 available now ok
I understand the idea made on age 7 but
I have prevented that
Jeremy I don't know really what a good
development plan is somehow this this
structure Steve still fields a little
bit a little bit worse for black yeah
maybe I have to do this for work the aid
mar 5 at the right moment but at the
moment I have look on da analysis looks
it does not look right five maybe you
can still do it well maybe it takes know
is just improving a little bit okay
let's just make it more difficult for
him to push me five I wonder if I can do
something really crazy like g5 age 5 and
X it looks crazier it really does age
maybe I mean h5 is maybe not that bad to
control this yeah but maybe maybe I
can't play that G 596 and it controls e5
and g4 is a threat but g 5a can go if
I've right yeah he really can go a 5v5
takes Knight eggs and at the end so I
have to do this probably
so maybe I should regroup here like
rookie 7 rookie aid I know it looks
purely defensive but it is not so clear
in fact if this is the case because our
long-term I have two bishops and when i
get to get to I am that's interesting
but I thought really takes okay I have
to take anyway h3 hangs the tee did he
not think about it oh I don't know I
this night h4 or what is exactly the
point well he has to check with the pawn
maybe
but still bishop age 39 th for Queen g5
take this night h4 queen g5 night for to
f3 Queen g-form think about it
I is king h no I can take that on on on
g2 is also threatening to take f4 so i'm
not sure that you really have another
more the weird thing is that here my
bishop has no move but and threaten
Bishop takes to do that's even possible
after King h2 and I didn't see a move
how he covers the f 39 so I thought that
Bishop g2 is really strong
rookie for maybe rookie for ism to
attack f4 then g5 well g5 going totally
crazy yeah but have to cover f-111 what
else and the detects age form definitely
yeah I wouldn't be surprised if there's
some way for him to know kill me but I
don't see it yeah I can take him check
yeah I'm totally totally winning yeah
funnier ok so the check and f3 check
white resigns yeah it's also f3m
blundering g5 but ok it's not a problem
i can i can do it say I can do f5 or
stuff like that I mean this is winning I
wonder about this it's really let's just
look at this tactical this tactical
really at the end so we had this and he
grabbed yet it's really not working
fania blackest black is winning after
this no no the computer goes down now it
goes up ok it's really useless to not
consult the computer him here played g5i
are the computer wants to take g2 anyway
which I don't understand why is rook F
for now not possible I'd wants to stress
to Jack give up the Queen and gives
black a good position yeah I can believe
that but does it mean that g5 is not
working no it is working
but there is a line that that we both
overlook to look at this here here and
this and my queen is strapped funny
enough is that the computer says that
this is you're going to laugh at me
equal it gives 0.1 x takes 0.1 yeah this
is probably not an evaluation that will
stand if you let it run let it let it
calculate a little bit it's a totally
crazy position yeah but this is nothing
enjoyable game thanks for watching